so somebody has that instinct and that
intuition that says they need to go out
and take a chance they just feel it do
you have any helpful hints or tricks
practice and how do you practice
intuition you practice intuition by not
shutting it down meaning all of you feel
something when you meet somebody or you
see something take a look like think
it's practice I'm telling you it's like
meditating playing tennis it's like you
practice kindness how do you practice
kindness when you see somebody in the
street who's a stranger and you actually
like their hoodie instead of just saying
it to yourself be like yo nice hoodie
bro that's called practicing kindness
attention is the number one asset we're
starting off season two with the big
fish Caris podcast with a bang like a
real bang like a big bang like a Big
Bang Theory Gary vaynerchuk Gary V I
don't think he needs an introduction uh
I think everyone knows who he is at
least people that probably follow me so
we're going to get right into it thanks
again for this opportunity I know I you
traded for it I know I traded for it did
a flip I know I appreciate you it's
great to see you I'm glad you're here I
wanted uh I wanted the experiences man
you've taught me that over the last 10
years that experiences Monsters the
stuff is cool experiences are 100x by
the way for everybody you can turn the
podcast off right now if you could just
actually hear that and then live it this
was the best podcast you ever lived uh
listened to excuse me because it's very
true my brother but let's get into it I
know we have a lot of time yeah and I uh
I was just talking to Gary before the
episode started about U my Journey over
the last 3 years and uh about how I'm
trying to harness this
energy and I listened to two podcasts
that you did um over this past year the
one was Steven Bartlett uh the diary of
the CEO which was an amazing that was my
probably my favorite podcast that you've
ever done yeah it was a good one the way
he interviews is really good um but the
stories that I got out of you the the
more in depth I got to learn about you
um your mom you know and I I I've gotten
pieces of your mom from being in the v
Friends Community speaking little
satellite events been hearing about Mom
I'm now starting to understand why
you're so special I because I was like
man like how does he do all this stuff
and how is he so happy all the time and
it's because of his mom uh and then also
then the the podcast that you did with
your fiance Mona and Chloe and uh you
guys talked about some interesting stuff
on that podcast uh with intuition energy
and so I want to kind of dive a little
bit deeper on that so um let's so let's
start with your mom right so your your
mom's had such a big impact on your life
and from now for I want to make like a
hypothesis I think that because of your
mother's love and compassion for you and
how she she uh rewarded kindness and
like I I heard like Parts like where
like you didn't do that well in school
no secret I didn't do that well in
school either I got in trouble a lot cuz
I you know lots of lots of different
lots of different reasons what are you
looking for looking for this when you
see it up close and personal it's pretty
bad but go ahead all right so but I
thought that was so cool when you said
that and so now fast forward to you know
35y old Gary and he's making an impact
on all these young entrepreneurs all
these content creators y entrepreneurs
content creators that's like the that's
the core and you're speaking life into
them you're believing in them and like I
didn't know you personally for the first
eight years I followed you yep but that
little bug in my ear really made an
impact on someone believing in me cuz
it's like yeah my mom was around and I
had a good mom it was just a different
kind of love right get and your mom's
got this I don't know this feminine
energy that she's instilled into you and
then you instill that and all these
people around the world and the impact
that you're making right now is like
still just like this on the grand scope
of things so my first question is like
how do you perceive the ripple effect of
your influence on entrepreneurs
like now and then forecasting that into
the future I think now it's
noticeable you know I don't think it's
you know a secret like the reality is is
that I've effectively communicated at
scale now for a decade 15 years or so
and we now have a generation of 22 23 33
year olds who really grew up with Gary
ve being out there right and so I think
there's an impact now I know that
because I get an outrageous amount of
email and DMS and I mean it's
inconceivable for me to be out in public
and not have someone come up to me and
say something nice about the impact I've
had you know that's I'm not really even
out in public that much I'm in the
office a lot and with family a lot so
like you know I'm aware it's there I'm
flattered and I think long term I don't
plan on stopping and I think vriends
ironically is like the two. over version
I know that I'm not everyone's cup of
tea I know I'm only one human being I
can't get to everyone and so I think the
thing that's really interesting about
entrepreneurial Elf or creative crab or
you know Gary B or empathy elephant is
I'm really going for it like the last
you know 20 years 15 years 10 years has
been about how much can I literally out
of the sheer will of a human accomplish
in changing The Narrative of success
having conversations with entrepreneurs
and humans that have
ambition and now I have a whole universe
of Marvel Pokemon Disney Sesame Street
like characters that I have to develop
over the next multiple decades and if
I'm right I can have a massive impact um
and um I think Star Wars had a big
impact on me interesting MH I haven't
said this publicly so I'm giving you
some Scoops here fish I want you to have
some good stuff I think Star Wars when I
was like 30 20 25 I was able to rewind
and say [__] no wonder I was so
attracted to Star Wars It's the story of
life it is that there is good and
there's evil and they're kind of
actually close in energy but good by the
tip of its nose will outpace bad you
know cuz [__] the dark side's rough
the emperor is a beast it's not like
Yoda can beat the emperor so easily and
and I think that that's the impact and
so when I saw that bless you Dustin when
I able when know at 30 or 35 when things
about Good and Evil and positive and
negative all these psychological things
became interesting to me I was able to
rewind why I was so attracted to those
characters and stories and what did Han
Solo or Chewbacca or Yoda or the emperor
greo even who made a quick appearance
mean to me that is my ambition for V
friends I want a 50-year-old in in 70
years to be like oh crap no wonder I'm
so accountable accountable ant was my
favorite character as a kid and I
learned quickly that accountability was
the quickest path to happiness and
blaming and pointing fingers was the
reverse and I believe today for example
a shocking amount of humans in America
and around the world but in America
there's a direct correlation to their
unhappiness on their ability to blame
everyone the president governments
bosses their parents and their capacity
of blame is what's leading to their
unhappiness that comes from culture
right it comes from politicians it comes
from television it comes from social
media it comes from mainstream media it
comes from what is popular in culture
when I started first talking about
hustle in 2008 because the economy was
bad I was revered for making people
happy that they were in control and if
they grinded it they could win eight
years later when the world was Fluffy
and overflowing with cash I was
demonized because people converted that
term into slang of burnout out M now I
can use hustle again instead of hard
work cuz we're now getting I mean I like
a year ago I'm like wait a minute people
are saying this in a good way again
there's always a
temperament right you know Pilots were
the most famous people in America 1960
nobody even thinks TW nobody even knows
One Pilot by name in America today yeah
pilots and astronauts that's right
that's I think I heard that on one those
podcast I mean uh major athletes I'm
talking in the Hall of Fame of baseball
and football had summer jobs because
they didn't get paid enough being
professional athletes and they would
work in a hardware store in the Bronx
this is real New York Yankees in the 50s
worked in Hoboken at a hardware retail
store during the off season cuz it
didn't pay enough like things change and
so to answer your question what's what's
happened now is we've created
entitlement because we're an empire in
First World countries around the world
and we haven't had a World War in a long
time and we're worrying about church
uary things not primary things we're not
worried about roof over our heads we're
worried that we don't have a
Mercedes and when we don't have a
Mercedes we blame someone that we don't
because we don't want to we're really
bad at being accountable this is why
accountable ant gets so much love for me
when I use
examples I want to
know you have such you know you're I I
remember you in the early days right a
lot of energy right you have you remind
me like myself like a lot of energy
Y how have you how have you harnessed
that energy and like Through The Years
um become more calm clam like and that's
a v friends yeah I I think that I still
have the same Basic Energy I'm just
empathetic that the temperament of our
society was demonizing energy as
something negative and I just decided to
take that was a thoughtful not even a
subconscious that was a thoughtful
decision that oh people are not hearing
me that's on me back to accountability
when people like Gary you just care
about money I'm like okay I'm not doing
a good job if someone believes that I'm
not doing a good job so I
consciously have you know changed up
energy in certain scenarios to make sure
my point is not being lost because I'm
trying to bring value and if you dismiss
me cuz you think I'm a jersey you know
Street kid and you're a academic and you
dismiss me well then I can't achieve the
good that I want to give you I'm not
hurt by it I'm not disrespected I'm not
mythed I'm not insecure about it I just
have a
mission and I'm enjoying my mission and
why do I why would I have the audacity
to say oh [__] you you don't get me and
no it's the reverse I have the
humility like a
hedgehog to say wait a minute I need to
mix this up and then also the things
that I talk about change as I become
more educated of what the issue is I
didn't realize 10 years ago how much
insecurity was stopping people from
doing the things I was telling them were
so easy to do to grow their thing
because you grew up in such an
environment where that wasn't my issue
correct I'm like I never dawned on me in
2006 that the reason somebody would not
start a YouTube channel was because they
were worried about somebody saying
they're ugly but by 2015 and 20 with my
popularity and getting all my DMs I
started reading the temperature of the
world and I'm like
oh these people buy these jewelry not
because they just want the jewelry cuz
that makes them look successful and
they're trying to prove to everyone
they're successful because they grew up
not feeling successful I just got done
interviewing uh Robin Hood the artist
our buddy and you know he grew up with a
dad that was really tough on him and
called him fat [__] and like and like
was really mean but that's also driven
him to go to the gym now of but he still
just told me just like an hour ago of
bik like that still sits with him that
in that that insecurity so the people
that don't grow up with moms like you do
you have any advice on on how to get
there get get get there get there get
there a little faster well no that word
scares me the faster part is why I think
people don't get there you know I have a
father who grew up with a totally
different mother and I was very affected
by that father so I've been thinking
about this [__] my whole life I'm not by
the way just so everybody understands
when they when I talk about my mom I
hope everybody understands I didn't grow
up in a fairy land I had a lot of things
I had a very different dad who had you
know who I have a great relationship
with but there was a there was 25 years
of work to get to where we are today uh
and that's me being a grownup at 20 to
to today I grew up being the oldest
child of an immigrant family I was told
from day one you take care of
everything do you know how many things I
[__] to a kid of course do you know how
many things I've [__] up in my life
because I'm always taking care of
everything so I have no angst towards my
parents it's a big you know this my big
theme at Von this year was [__] your
grandparents right which is not [__]
your grandparents I love people's
grandparents I'm saying if you're be mad
at your mom or your dad
well don't you know that they had a mom
and dad that made them the way they are
so if you're going to be like my parents
[__] me up so [__] my parents well no
no no no no no you need to be mad at
your grandparents CU they [__] up your
parents and shouldn't go there and by
the way I don't know if you've heard
there's something called
great-grandparents yeah and like so goes
all the way back to Adam and Eve you
believe in the Bible right you know so
these are the things I think about
constantly and of course there's gifts
and curses that came along with being a
human I just think we're spending way
too much time right now on the curses I
think we need to be more grateful and
optimistic the other thing that you talk
about your mom is that she's that she's
giv you the gift of intuition yep and I
have a bunch of questions on intuition
like first off like do you think
that do you think everyone has intuition
I think everyone has intuition I don't
think people I think there's levels to
it I think everybody can play
basketball like I don't know like all
four of us in the room right now could
go outside right now and play basketball
yeah my intuition on that is we will not
look like the New York Knicks that play
at M regard and no matter how bad of a
basketball team they are they are
dramatically better than the four of us
I think a lot of people have been told
not to believe in intuition which means
they haven't practiced intuition I think
a lot of people are scared to get hurt
so they don't go under intuition because
when they have in the past somebody hurt
them and they're scared to get hurt
again um I think there's a lot that goes
into intuition but for me intuition is
everything now you were blessed with
like that that mother again so like your
intuition probably have to a little bit
faster of a start I think there's a
direct correlation to intuition and
self-esteem okay so I think it takes
risk to follow your intuition and I
think if you're not scared that someone
can hurt you because you have your own
self-esteem you'll practice intuition
more I also don't worry about the money
as an entrepreneur so I'm I'm okay with
losing it I could tell how much is the
rent here by the way I'm I'm a I'm a
Midwest guy I'm a Midwest guy so came
into the Big Apple in the New York City
and they told me the whole floor and I
walked around saw all the glass like all
these views are like billion dollar
views like I can't even imagine what the
rent cost and I saw the ebit shirt last
night and and like me and you run our
businesses very similar my ebit sucks
yeah because I'm always invested inure
that's right people by the way this is a
very meta conversation I've met a lot of
Benny I've met thousands of high energy
dudes that like are going on the offense
with me and 99% of them I don't build
any form of a relationship with because
my intuition is like this doesn't have
the right intent or this is just
transactional oh transactional
commission breath it's got commission
bre and so with you I'm just like you
know what I bet you a lot of people see
this kid as like n but I see this kid as
yeah and so here we are
today and I gave you a big stack of
vends cards no that's today to hear but
you would have never been able to even
give me those vend cards if I didn't
make those four to five decisions on the
other times I saw you yeah that's we
would have not like you could have given
there are people who can give me the V
friends like everything like the human
for there are people who can give me a
$5 million to have a relationship with I
wouldn't even comprehend it I'm really
appreciative of it I have a lot of I
have a lot of gratitude for it because
it is uh it's awesome when someone
believes in you especially like when you
and then they actually meet that person
and then it's actually happening and
it's actually working and it's like wow
and then that just builds momentum yeah
and then there's this ripple effect that
I kind of started and it's like now
that's infecting all my people it's
going to affect my kids it's going to
affect all my relationships because I
struggled with relationships for many
years of course because I didn't
know it was it was clanky it was clanky
until you love yourself you can't love
anyone
else until you trust yourself you can't
trust anyone else until you're
comfortable with making mistes mistakes
with yourself you can't be comfortable
with others making
mistakes the number one reason I have so
much compassion for everyone else is I
have compassion for myself I'm a human
I'm not a superhero I'll make
mistakes yeah I'm trying not to I prefer
not to are you because at the end of the
day like isn't one of the theories like
hey fail fast and like you know no no
that that is a slang term for are you
willing to take a chance knowing it may
not work out but you still like every
one of my chances I'd prefer to work but
I'll take the booby prize of learning
gotcha you know what I mean whereas
other people I think are so scared that
if it doesn't work that it completely
represents their entire self-esteem that
they don't even try cuz why would you
risk hurting yourself so much so
somebody has that instinct and that
intuition that says they need to go out
and take a chance right they're
listening to Gary they're seeing what
they he's got to say they just feel it
how do you have any helpful hints or
tricks practice and how do you practice
intuition you practice intuition by not
shutting it down meaning all of you feel
something when you meet somebody or you
see
something take a take take a look like
think it's practice I'm telling you it's
like meditating it's like playing tennis
it's like you practice kindness how do
you practice kindness Gary I don't know
when you see somebody in the street
who's a stranger and you actually like
their hoodie instead of just saying it
to yourself be like yo nice hoodie
bro that's called practicing
kindness uh the next time you have a
quick second of I like this person but
then all the things your mom and dad and
you taught yourself like no no no
they're going to hurt me well just
remember for a quick second remember
that Nan before you went to your normal
state where you're like I think I like
this person well that time jump in and
oh by the way when they [__] you don't
think that that's how it always see Gary
you're a [__] [__] you made me
trust this person they [__] me no no
no do it again and get it's [__]
practice it's I'm like the opposite of
Alan Iverson Alan Iverson practice [__]
I'm like no no everything is
practice obviously I loved his point and
I love my point which is like you want
to grow intuition you have to jump in
all two feet into your intuition every
time you can recognize that your
intuition is telling you to go even
though your brain's telling you to know
if you can balance your stomach with
your brain you will be a [__] monster
and most people either are too
delusional and just use their stomach
and they're always getting [__] over
cuz they're not using their [__]
brain or like most people I see they're
just using their brain and they've been
taught and have learned how to
completely shut down their intuition and
so they're onedimensional and
everything's very linear the one thing
I've learned since Co um was meditation
and I've actually started to do that I
don't do it as much as I probably should
to get still brother there's no should
well there's some people that meditate
every day there's some people but I know
that it work every time I meditate I
feel so much better should I get super I
get super let's talk about this for the
last few seconds [__] like you should
meditate every day when I hear I feel so
much better you need to hear yourself
and rewind this and clip this with your
Cody and like really understand no no no
do you shower every day yeah okay you
should meditate every day because guess
what and it I bet you like most dudes
somewhere in sixth seventh or eighth
grade even though your mom was or
someone or the world or somebody said
you stunk and you knew you had a shower
every day you still weren't we weren't
in practice yet I remember being in
[__] e8th grade and like know that's
when it's like starts to get the real
with the girls and everything and I'm
like I don't want to [__] show I
would go three days without showering
and then somewhere in I think between
freshman year of high around freshman
year high school is a whole new world
you know I think High School is when I
started to well guess what if you can
shower every day you can definitely
meditate every day have you dudes don't
want to shower have you have you went
have you had any experiences that were
like long
um that that gives you that Vision right
cuz I know that I've had experiences
where like I'll meditate or I'll go
somewhere for like a day or two to get
clear Visions so that way I can figure
out what I want to do in the future um
so that way I can start practicing and
now is there anything that you do that's
really wor to create a bigger Vision
yeah but I think this is really rough I
always I kind of cuz I think this is I I
think I'm in some sort of like Advanced
State that's what you are I feel like
I'm meditating and thinking and being
thoughtful every second I even said to
Dustin [__] yesterday that I had this
weird Revelation the last month that I
think I'm thinking fully at night and i'
never like like I this weird conscious
while sleeping what's up yeah like while
I'm sleeping yeah like I had this weird
thing happened twice now in the last
month I feel like something's getting to
the front of my head from the back of my
head where like I never remember
anything none of my dreams none of my
everything and like two times now in the
last 3 weeks I feel like I've got an
answer to something and I can recall
thinking about it when I was sleeping
yeah cuz I I think I deep sleep so I
think a lot of people like sleep and
like so they can remember a lot of [__]
cuz they're like half in and half out
I'm like out I think your ability to be
present like you're so present like for
everyone the people that don't really
know you and they think oh he's all over
the place he on social media like every
time I've been around you it is amazing
how like locked in and I think that that
leads to when you brushed your head at
night you're able to like be so clear
because you're not worrying about the
future you're not worrying about the
past I think that that helps drive that
brain a little bit to answer your
question um it I just think I'm
meditating some version of meditation at
all times I'm always trying to be
thoughtful I'm always trying to be in
the middle I'm not trying to let my like
I just have a good relationship with
myself that's what I I want people to
love themselves because I think the
things that I watch trigger everyone
around me is a direct correlation to
their relationship with themselves as
this information gets more mainstream
right and it gets out there I even heard
you talk about the subject of like
psychedelic
what are yours psychedelics like
unlocking potential think it's huge I
think it's huge I'm not educated but in
my gut in my intuition do I believe that
there are a lot of people today who that
same exact type of person let just
actually if that same person was born 30
years later and everything was the same
that when the world accepts psych micro
doing and things of that nature that
those people would be able to use that
medicine the way many people today live
much longer cuz we have modern medicine
like you know there used to not be
penicillin and then there was do I
believe stuff that's from the earth
managed properly in the right dosage
could have a humongous impact on many
people around the world yes I do do I
know anything past that not really I've
watched a couple docs here I've listened
to my psychedelic friends hey the day
after vcon we go on an experience but I
think I cuz I think you'd be the best
guy in the world you're already but you
know what the problem is I'm actually
I'm actually fearful of a lot of things
because I'm so happy I'm like what if it
[__] tweaks me the other way oh
that's true too yeah so one of the
reasons I've kind of you do have a
little fear that's good listen I have I
have huge fear of the health and
wellness of my family and I have huge
fear of doing something that would
change the trajectory of my happiness
why would I do that all right I got to
get out of here question yeah last one
um we've had the opportunity to interact
now thankfully because of the V Friends
Community a lot more hang out hwk talk
meeting you in person a bunch of times
what has been your impression of me and
those interactions and what do you think
about me I believe that you kind of took
my thunder in the beginning of this I
believe that your natural
DNA if you grew up the same exact way
cuz it's not just my mom it's my mom
it's 1980s New Jersey America you know I
grew up outside 8 10 hours a day
starting at 7 to 14 my mom didn't have a
[__] clue where I was she know it was
in the general area but like I believe
that if you grew up that you everything
that is you but you lived my exact life
born in bellarus to everything the same
that that we would have a lot of
similarities and I think that attracts
me to you but I don't believe that's
what happened to you and so as you can
imagine you stole my thunder because I
do believe what I'm attracted to is the
people that I want to affect by what I
am as a byproduct of how it happened in
a positive way because I have so much
positivity to give and it's fun to watch
the micro doing that I'm putting into
people that's moving them down the path
and I believe the far majority of them
that have been po committed to it are
better than they are happier not better
are happier today than the day before
they found me and I'm proud of that what
do you think about me though personally
I'm curious about you I think you're a a
Tor to force that you're you're chaotic
and that you're going to hone it the way
I have and I think that you're very
entrepreneurial I think you're a big
personality and I think when it's too
much it's not good and when it's not
enough it's not good and so you have red
and blue moments way more red and blue
moments than I have but that you're on
your path to
purple I like that does that make sense
uh it does make sense I really appre I
think you have two way more black I I
use red and blue because of politics I
talk about purple lot but let's use the
other one I think you have way more
day-to-day interactions and moments in
your life that are either black or white
and I believe I'm constantly gray and I
believe that and I'm and I believe that
you are getting more gray literally
every six months that I see you and I
think that will lead you to the place
that you can sense you're on well I'm
really excited about the new
announcement uh yeah la is going to be
fun La is going to be cool and it's
going to be different you know we've
taken over Minnesota and Indianapolis
we're trying something different yeah
we're going we're we're even when you
see some of the details come out we're
going to let the V friends play a little
bit in the big city and so we'll see
what that feels like and we'll learn
from that I really appreciate the time
today everybody knows how to get a hold
of Gary if they need to I don't need to
do that on this part of the podcast if
you guys got value out of this podcast
like subscribe comment leave a comment
for this man like give him feedback on
his interviewing style so that he can
build cuz he'll value it what's one
question I should have asked you that I
didn't how how devastated are you that
the jet season's a piece of [__] after
it was supposed to be so good I'm a
Browns fan so like it's yours is going
well yeah chubby yours is going well W I
know the chub thing hurts but yours is
still going well chub you got a lot of
stuff yeah QB is different than RB
thanks all right love
[Music]
you